Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Morning. My name is Mark Wood.
I'm an elder here at Henderson Hills for the past couple
of years and it's a privilege to get to present God's word
to you today from Psalm 63.
Um, Amy
and I, my wife have been members, uh, from about 2005
or oh six and uh, we have three grown kids
and I like to run.
And uh, so those are the things you
probably need to know about me.
Um, today we're gonna look at Psalm 63
and if you can stand, would you please stand
as we read Psalm 63.
It says that this is a Psalm
of David when he was in the wilderness of Judah.
Oh God, you are my God.
Earnestly I seek you my soul thirsts for you.
My flesh faints for you as in a dry
and weary land where there is no water.
So I have looked upon you in the sanctuary beholding your
power and glory because your steadfast
love is better than life.
My lips will praise you, so I will bless you as long
as I live in your name.
I will lift up my hands.
My soul will be satisfied as with fat and rich food.
And my mouth will praise you
with joyful lips when I remember you upon my bed
and meditate on you in the watches of the night.
For you have been my help.
And in the shadow of your wings, I will sing for joy.
My soul clings to you. Your right hand upholds me.
But those who seek to destroy my life shall go down
into the depths of the earth.
They shall be given over to the power of the sword.
They shall be a portion for jackals,
but the king shall rejoice in God.
All who swear by him shall exalt for the mouths
of liars will be stopped.
Let's pray. Father, we thank you for your word.
That's powerful and true.
We thank you for this record of David's life
and we look for your Holy Spirit to teach us
and to show us how to apply this scripture so
that we can live in victory in Christ's name.
Amen. You can be seated.
Well, most of your Bibles will say that this was a Psalm
of David as it said that
as he was heading into the wilderness
and the wilderness of Judea is south of Jerusalem.
He was fleeing someone at the time.
And there are two thoughts about who this might be.
The first thought is that in first, uh, second Samuel 15
through 18, David was fleeing Absalom, his son
as he rushed into the desert
to get away from Absalom's wrath
as he overtook the kingdom temporarily.
And then other scholars think that maybe this was the record
of David fleeing Saul.
And there's a whole nother passage
of scripture one Samuel 16 through 31,
where David is fleeing Saul on multiple occasions.
But needless to say, David is fleeing.
He's fleeing for his life.
He's headed out away from everything
that he knows from the comforts of home, from his friends,
from food, and he's headed into the wilderness.
And you might ask, well, what is the wilderness?
It's a place with no food or water, no shelter, no friends.
And maybe most importantly no place,
no formal place of worship.
The arc of the covenant was back in Jerusalem.
The tabernacle at the time is back in Jerusalem.
And David is leaving all of these things,
these familiar things that were things of comfort,
but also things of worship.
And he's fleeing into a lonely place
that can be lonely and dangerous.
So he's writing of this desert experience,
this very real physical desert.
But he's also talking about some things that are deeper,
some separation from things that comfort is soul.
And maybe some of you are fleeing some things today.
Perhaps you're in a wilderness experience also.
Perhaps you have some hurts
or some fearful things
that you're struggling with some health issues.
Perhaps you have a loved one
or a job that is hard to deal with right now
or something painful, physical
and emotional, something that you are struggling with.
Certainly the trials of life can feel like we're lacking
or alone, feel like we're struggling on our own
or that someone is out there to harm us.
I've got two examples of struggles that I've dealt with.
One is kind of funny I think,
and the other is just dealing with life.
But the funny one is, uh,
I've run the Pallo Dura Canyon race a couple of times.
The pal Dura Canyon is a canyon in Texas near Amarillo
and it's kind of desert-like,
and they have races there that people voluntarily sign up
for to go run, believe it or not.
And I remember the last time I ran the 50 K race,
it was hot, it was dry.
And on the second lap of 17 miles,
my fingers looked like sausages.
And I was wondering why did I do this? But you know what?
I signed up for it.
And the only people that were behind me were the few people
that I'd been able to pass along the way
that weren't as fast as me.
Nobody was chasing me to kill me.
There were water stops along the way for me
and I could have stopped at any point in time.
So that's the funny wilderness experience.
But I think many of you may have other
experiences like this One.
Another wilderness experience for me is just some
of the things that life brings
that make your soul feel dry and hungry.
I know that over the past several years I've
lost some close friends.
They've either passed or moved away
and I feel some sense of aloneness and abandonment
because I don't have them anymore.
They're not close. I've had some health issues,
nothing real serious,
but things that change my capabilities, I can't sustain some
of the things that I used to do.
I can't do some things.
And those are changes that are forever.
And I look back on my youth
and I long for some of those things
or I've made some professional changes
that have changed my perspective on my job.
And I'm looking at the end now.
You know, I'm looking at retirement somewhere out there
in the next several years.
And so I wonder if the changes
that I've made have prepared me.
As I look at retirement, there are questions
that leave me unsettled.
There're issues that make me feel alone.
There are things that make me long for fellowship
and I wonder how is God leading me
through these hard things?
If we look back to what David wrote, he stated in verse one
that his flesh was fainting and the land was dry
and weary with no water.
And this is definitely an true physical picture
of the landscape, what it looked like around him,
what he was going through.
But again, the psalm is looking deeper than just the
physical circumstances because David faced a lot
of this for many years.
I don't wanna minimize the circumstances that he faced,
but what we're going to see is that David was dealing
with some issues of his heart
and we're gonna get a glimpse into his heart
and mind as he approached his relationship with God.
And so that's kind of what I wanna look at today.
As we look at Psalm 63, there are four things
that I hope we can learn today from Psalm 63.
First, I want us to see that
in our wilderness experience, whatever we're dealing with,
that God is present
and powerful, God is
present and powerful.
Let's look at verse one, how that it starts.
Data starts with the Psalm saying, God, you are my God.
The word, the first word for God is Elohim.
It's the great and mighty powerful God,
the Almighty God, the only God.
And David is saying that you the mighty, all powerful, only
magnificent God are my God.
I belong to you and I acknowledge you.
I know that you are powerful. I'm on the run.
People wanna kill me.
I'm rejected by so many other people
but you, you are my God.
In the midst of this wilderness, I'm seeking you.
One of the ways that many
of us might handle our wilderness experience is
to just look at the circumstances
and be overcome by the circumstances that we face.
We might like me look for the way out.
Be sure I've got all the angles covered.
Look for the ways to protect myself.
And while we certainly did be aware of how to face the
realities of life, the psalmist is reminding us
that in times like this, we need to remember that God is God
and ever present
and he's the same powerful God in the midst
of these circumstances that he was
before we entered the circumstances, he's present
and he hasn't left us alone and he's powerful.
What David is showing us is that in the midst of this,
we can have fellowship with him
as we go through this struggle.
The Psalmist says in the middle of his trial,
earnestly, I seek you.
This earnestness is a a eager pursuit,
a struggle looking for God, desiring God.
It's the it. He gives it the picture that we all know
what it feels like to be thirsty.
It's this longing for fellowship with God.
It's a fleshly discomfort that we can relate
to deep down in our spirits.
This could be compared to the parable
of the woman that you remember.
She had 10 coins and she lost one of them.
And it says that she eagerly diligently searched the house
looking until she found the coin.
And of course the difference in that parable is
that the coin was lost
and she was searching for something that was lost for us.
We can be assured
that we are never lost from God's presence.
If he is your savior, he never leaves us alone.
Proverbs 1810 reminds us that the name
of the Lord is a strong tower.
The righteous man or the Godly person runs to it
and is protected.
And so in the midst of our wilderness, we run
to our faithful protecting powerful God.
So to follow David's example, as he goes
through his wilderness, he's enthusiastically seeking
to draw near to God for safety, for sustenance.
And as we'll see a little bit later for worship,
he describes his need for fellowship with God
because his soul is empty and dry
and he recognizes this deep need for God.
It's like a deep craving for water, food,
shelter, and safety.
He's craving really for something that only God can give
to him and that's what he's acknowledging.
So what does David do?
He remembers the times of worship in the tabernacle
in the middle of his wilderness.
He remembers this picture.
He says, so I have looked upon you
in the sanctuary beholding your power and glory.
The word so here means in the same way, just
as I looked at you when I was in Jerusalem,
I was looking at you in the tabernacle.
So here in the middle of this desert, I'm looking to you.
I'm looking for your presence.
I'm seeking you in the middle of this desert.
At that time, the tabernacle
and the Ark of the Covenant represented
God's presence for the people.
It's where God's power
and glory was displayed in times of peace.
Imagine David worshiping at
that time in the tabernacle there would be songs,
there would be trumpets, harps, there would be incense,
there would be the smell of sacrifices, the bleeding
of the animals that were coming in to be sacrificed.
There would be crowds rushing around him.
And David is remembering all of this as he is in the middle
of the desert, remembering that God's presence was real
and that he can have this,
even though he doesn't have the formal things of worship
around him, he can have God's presence with him
as he is in the desert, in the wilderness.
So the day, the reason
that David can approach God this way is clarified
for us in verse three,
because your steadfast love is better than life.
My lips will praise you.
Is there anything that is better than life? Yes.
David says, your steadfast love is better than life.
He uses the word here in the scripture, it says, has said,
and for us has said is translated with two words
steadfast love.
What does steadfast mean?
It's the surety, the faithfulness of God, the the sureness
of the one that we are following.
It's the sureness that God will fulfill, the obligation
that he's made to those that he's called.
It's a sure thing.
It's like some of you may remember the ads, the rock
of the of Gibraltar.
It's the sure rock that will always be there.
That's why you should have Prudential insurance.
I'm not making a plug, but more commonly
for us, it's the sureness
that the day is gonna happen again tomorrow.
We're gonna have a sunrise tomorrow.
The sun will come up as long as God intends for it to,
there will be a sunrise.
God is sure he is faithful. He will follow through.
And the word love, what does that mean for us?
Well, for us, who are his followers?
It's God's affection towards us.
His goodness and kindness, his good intentions,
his favorable disposal towards us, the way
that he deals with those whom he's called.
So David is looking to God in his steadfast love
and he can be confident as he goes through his desert
because he realizes that God has
steadfast love towards him.
We can find the same kind
of truth proclaimed in the New Testament in verses like
Romans 8 28, God is working all things together
for good, for those who are called according to his purpose.
Does it mean that you won't experience hard things?
No, you're gonna experience hard things,
but God's favorable disposition towards you is there.
And the sureness of his promise is there.
He will show his steadfast love to those
who are called according to his purpose
in the middle of the wilderness.
David Basks in God's loving kindness
and care for him, knowing that
this love is better than life.
And so he praises God.
So first, remember that God is present
and powerful no matter what the circumstances look like.
The second thing that this passage brings
to our attention is how we relate to God in worship.
And it makes it clear that God can be worshiped both in
community, as we talked about in the temple.
It was a tabernacle at the time,
but also in solitude in the wilderness
experiences that we go through.
David cried out in verse two.
So I have looked upon you in the sanctuary beholding
your power and glory.
He's worshiped in crowds
with priests performing all their duties
and all of the things we described earlier.
David remembers all these formal worship experiences.
And in the New Testament we're reminded
that we should have the same kinds of worship experiences
verses like Colossians three 16, let the word
of Christ dwell in you richly teaching
and admonishing one another in all wisdom, singing Psalms
and hymns and spiritual songs
with thankfulness in your hearts to God.
Is that not what we've done this morning
with all the beautiful songs that we sang earlier,
reminding us of God's faithfulness,
his favorable disposition towards us.
And then Hebrews 10, 24
and 25, let us consider how to stir one another up
to love and good works.
Not neglecting to meet together as is the habit of some,
but encouraging one another
and all the more as you see the day drawing near.
So just like David, we can get a sense that we need
to meet together, we need to come together to worship,
for teaching, for singing, for mutual encouragement
as we worship God.
But we also know that we should worship God when we're alone
daily as we live.
And most certainly when we're going
through our wilderness experiences.
The best example we have of this is Jesus.
Mark 1 35 through 37 tells us
and rising early in the morning while it was still
dark, he departed.
That is Jesus departed and went out to a lonely place
and there he prayed and it says Simon
and those who were with him searched
for him and they found him.
So he went to a lonely place alone to pray,
to spend time with the Father.
How do we navigate the times
that we feel like we're in a wilderness?
How can we ensure that our soul needs are met?
Well, David would tell us that we need to cry out to God
in times of personal worship.
We need to focus on God's goodness and power
and might engaging in worship as we go
through the wilderness of life, as we go
through the hardships that we face, we can feel tired,
hungry, and the thirst should remind us
that we need this relationship with God
and it should lead us to worship.
We need to be careful not to purposefully isolate ourselves
from others, but sometimes we may be isolated
and we can worship in those experiences.
We shouldn't neglect the resources that he's lovingly
provided for us, but there may be times that we don't feel
or have those resources around us
and we can worship in those times.
Prayer gives us the avenue to cry out to God,
to express what's deep within us.
And perhaps even song does that as well.
Our burdens can be laid at his feet pleading
for provision songs.
Let us cry in another way, expressing our love
and our faith in God.
God's word feeds our soul with truth
and instructs us how to live.
And meditation allows us
to ruminate over the truths that God's given us.
Imagine a cow cooing chewing the cudd.
And you all know that cows have four stomachs, right?
It goes from one to the next,
ruminating getting every particle out.
And that's what meditation is supposed to be for us.
Ruminating over, pulling out the truths
and allowing God to give us ways of application.
We have other resources that David didn't have.
We have community groups.
We have Celebrate Recovery, which is a ministry associated
with ministries of Jesus.
We have grief share. We have discipleship groups.
We have many ways that we can lean into resources
that God has given us.
So we have to use all these resources as we traverse
through our wilderness worship God as we go
through the wilderness, not just when we're in
a comfortable place.
And this brings us to the third truth
that this Psalm displays for us
and this illustrated in verses four through eight.
We can trust God to resolve life's hardships.
He will see us through the wilderness.
We can trust that he will feed the hungry soul
and will he'll, he'll give water to the soul who thirsts.
David didn't know exactly how it was gonna end.
He was on the run, people were chasing him.
He's in the middle of hunger and need, but he trusted God
and he says in verse four, so I will bless you
as long as I live.
David's saying again in the same way
or in the same manner going forward as I go
through this hardship, I'm going to bless you.
I'm going to worship you.
I can trust that you're going to resolve this.
He's saying, I'm in need now.
I'm suffering now,
but I can trust that you're going to resolve it,
that you're going to see me through.
I know that again, my personal tendency is
to focus on the hardship, maybe to complain, uh, maybe
to think about the circumstances
and look for areas of failure.
But this psalm in this Psalm, David reminds me
that I need to do the opposite.
I need to focus my attention on God's goodness and power
and be reminded of God's glory
because this is how he will see me through this kind
of trust is illustrated in the New Testament for us.
Also, do you remember the story shortly
after Jesus had left the earth after his death
and burial and resurrection?
Peter was arrested
and it says that Peter was in chains asleep
between two guards.
Imagine that he, he was surely facing persecution,
maybe death the next day.
And it says that Peter was asleep and God rescued him.
Or we have the picture of Paul and Silas.
They were arrested in Philippi and they were beaten
and put in chains and they were with the jailer.
It says, and what were they doing?
They were singing God's praises in the midst
of their hard time.
Why? Because they knew that God was at work even
through their hard time
and that God would be the one who delivered them.
David says, because I see your power
and might displayed in the sanctuary, I will bless you
in all circumstances at all times.
He's filling his mind with all the goodness of God so
that he doesn't focus on the very real suffering
that he was experiencing at the time.
One of my favorite passages is, is in Philippians four,
and I'll just look at verse eight, finally, brothers
and sisters, whatever is true, whatever is honorable,
whatever is just, whatever is pure, whatever is lovely,
whatever is commendable, if there is any excellence,
if there is anything worthy of praise,
think about these things.
We tend to be shaped by the things
that we focus our attention on.
And Paul reminds us here to focus on things
that are wonderful and good
and true so that we can trust
God's deliverance and purpose.
The result of this type
of worship is seen in verse five of the Psalm.
My soul will be satisfied as with fat and rich food,
and my mouth will praise you with joyful lips.
The word satisfied here means to eat one's fill
or to drink to one's fill.
And I'm pretty sure that most of you got a chance
to do this about two days ago
or three days ago, you ate your favorite foods.
You can remember even now, maybe the textures and the tastes
and the way that it felt to be with company of people
that love you and want to be with you.
And you were satisfied if you didn't eat too much,
you felt comfort and you felt sustained.
And that's the picture that David has for us here.
He's reminding us through the metaphor of food
that we can have that same kind of comfort as we look
to the goodness of God and trust God as we go
through our wilderness experience.
The innermost part of our beings can be satisfied as we look
to God to meet our needs and to satisfy our longings.
Verse seven describes the safety that comes
to the soul who trusts in God.
For you have been my help.
And in the shadow of your wings, I will sing for joy.
This is the protective covering that's
so frequently mentioned throughout scripture,
both in the Old Testament and the New Testament.
We see pictures of a bird, a hen in some places
covering the young with protection.
And we see this picture used in Ruth chapters two
and three where Ruth came under the protective
covering of Boaz.
We see it mentioned through several of the Psalms
and then we see it also mentioned
by Jesus himself in the New Testament.
Matthew 23,
Jesus is crying out over Jerusalem when he says Jerusalem.
Jerusalem, the city that kills the prophets
and stones, those who are sent to it.
How often would I have gathered your children together
as a hen gathers her brooded under her wings?
We see this picture of a protective covering
and that's what David is referring to.
You might ask, how do I know
that I'm under God's protection?
How do I know in the midst of my hardship when I can't
understand what my health is gonna do,
when I can't pay my bills or a loved one is suffering?
We need to remember God's countenance towards
those whom he's called.
Remember his steadfast love, his powerful presence.
He will oversee us with his mighty power.
He will work for a purpose through what we're going through.
So in the mis, in the middle of our desert experience
or David's desert experience, he's reminded
of all the goodness of God
and that God's wings are protecting him.
Verse eight tells us that David is clinging to God,
but more importantly, God is holding him.
It says, my soul clings to you. Your right hand upholds me.
And as followers of Christ, we should be clinging
to the truth that he's shown us.
But we need to remember
that our security is not in our holding,
but it's in God's sustaining hold on us.
God holds us with his hands.
Romans eight is one
of the most powerful declarations of this.
And I'm gonna read the whole passage here.
Romans 8 35 through 38,
who shall separate us from the love of Christ?
Shall tribulation or distress or persecution or famine
or nakedness or danger or sword?
No. In all these things we're more than conquerors
through him who loved us.
For I am sure that neither death nor life, nor angels
nor rulers, nor things present, nor things to come,
nor powers nor height, nor depth
nor anything else in all creation, will be able
to separate us from the love
of God in Christ Jesus our Lord.
What a list of hardships.
Paul mentions here,
or the writer of Romans mentions here what a list of things
that we might think could separate us from God's love.
But he assures us, no, none of these things can separate us.
God is true and God is faithful
and he has a has said love for us.
This is the truth we have to clinging to.
And this brings us to the last point I'd like
to emphasize from this psalm.
We can rejoice in God's goodness now
and we can look forward to God's goodness in the future.
Verses nine through 11, describe some really graphic
outcomes for victims of war at that time.
For David, his son's chasing him
and forcing him into the desert.
For some of us, it's other things.
Maybe it's some powerful person
or power you think that's trying to destroy your life.
Is there someone that continually robs you of joy?
Is there someone opposing you because you're a child of God?
Is there a deep hurt you're carrying around?
Is there a harmful habit you've picked up
that's damaging your peace?
There's so many ways that our soul can be attacked,
leaving us dry and barren,
and we can feel like we're gonna be overtaken.
Just like David feeling like he could be overtaken
by his enemies, it reveals our desperate need
for God's work in our life, for his saving work.
And as a child of God, we have to remember
that he has us in his palm,
that his steadfast love is caring for us
and that he will see us through.
And this is the language that David is using here.
It's it's a a truth that we need to clinging to that God
will see us through that.
He will carry us through the hardship. Okay?
We might face hard times. We won't always be prosperous.
We will have to suffer, but he will see us through,
and that's what I'm saying, that we can deal with God.
We can trust God to deal with us faithfully.
Two Corinthians four paints a beautiful picture of this
for us because it illustrates how fragile we are
and yet how faithful God is, verse seven.
But if we have this treasure in jars of clay,
that we have this treasure in jars of clay to show
that the surpassing power belongs to God and not to us.
We are afflicted in every way, but not crushed, perplexed,
but not given to despair, persecuted but not forsaken.
Struck down, but not destroyed, always carrying in the body,
the death of Jesus so that the life
of Jesus may also be manifested in our bodies, for we
who live are always being given over to death
for Jesus' sake, so that the life
of Jesus may be manifested in our mortal flesh
as followers of Christ.
We have resources that David didn't have.
David didn't have the continual presence of the Holy Spirit.
David didn't have the published word of God to look at day
by day that we have.
David didn't have the church fellowship that we have.
We have resources that David looked forward to
as he looked forward to the coming of the Messiah.
So Christian brother or sister,
if you're in a wilderness experience now, take advantage
of all the resources that God has given you.
Remember his steadfast love.
Remember his faithful, powerful presence.
Don't forsake the community of fellowship,
but figure out how to worship God as you go
through the wilderness and then trust the promises
that God has given you that you can look forward
to God delivering you through.
If there's anyone here who has.